SHARAD JONES: Hey, everyone.
Welcome back.
So in today's video, we're
going to be talking about--
I'm sorry, my shirt
keeps blinking
in and out of existence.
The sun's coming right
in, so it's just--
we'll talk about
machine learning
and how it does this detection
and why it's failing.
So don't worry.
This is all part
of the plan, right?
But hopefully, it's
not too distracting.
But either way, in
today's lecture,
we'll be talking
about Amazon Redshift.
So in Amazon Redshift--
maybe I can just shift this.
I have a light--
or something I'm trying
to block the light with.
So hopefully, that'll
make it slightly better
on one side at least.
But either way, with Amazon
Redshift, up until now,
at least, we've been
talking about RDS.
So that's relational
database service,
that's Amazon's relational
database service-- a fully
managed service in the cloud.
And here, I'll blink
to the next slide.
And that has served us
well and, to some extent,
encompasses the vast
majority of database work.
But RDS or
specifically, Redshift,
will give us a little bit of
a variation on that, that will
justify the use case for it.
But either way, to
review briefly on RDS,
what it is, as I was
saying, a completely managed
relational database
as a service.
So that means that we are--
we can choose the hardware type.
Really, that's going to be
through the instance type.
So we chose T2 micro, for
example, or whatever it was.
And you can alter--
you can choose
that instance type
set to optimize performance,
memory, I/O, whatever it may be,
for your specific use case.
You also have a choice
of the database engine.
And the nice thing, though, is
being a database or, basically,
a managed service, it's going to
handle all of the back-end admin
tasks, so the actual
hardware provisioning,
making sure things stay up to
date, the database gets set up,
patches, updates, OS updates, as
well as actual software updates,
security updates.
And remember we saw how we could
do that on a regular cadence,
or schedule that to
be done only nightly
or whenever they come up,
but only in the evenings.
So, all these things
really allow us
to just set it and forget it.
And then they will handle--
AWS's RD-- or Amazon's
RDS will handle
all of the rest of
the management aspect.
These are running on
individual virtual instances.
And we have max capacity there.
You can see 32
vCPUs, so 32 cores.
32 CPUs.
Cores is totally
a different count.
And then up to 244 gigs of
RAM, 64 terabytes of storage.
So for, I mean, the
vast, vast majority
of use cases, that's
plenty sufficient.
I mean, if you think about
the standard laptop you're
running on, even if you were
doing some really hardcore
development, you probably
don't have more than 32,
maybe 64 gigabytes of RAM.
244 gigabytes of RAM, that's
truly a server-scale operation.
Same with 32 vCPUs or even
64 terabytes of storage.
So, again, for
most things you're
going to be doing,
unless you know
you're going to be in
a different workspace
or different use
case, for most things,
RDS is going to
serve those needs.
But Redshift is saying,
what if you know our problem
is a bit bigger or maybe even
just a little bit different
or differently specified?
So it's still a fully
managed service,
though it's explicitly a
data warehouse as a service.
And so, with a database
or a relational database,
we're just talking
about a set of--
yeah, a set of tables that
fall under the umbrella of one
of our databases.
But a data warehouse is
really kind of a larger scale
tool that handles
not only the data
analy-- or the kind of
database storage and whatnot,
but also potentially the
actual storage of raw data.
Maybe even some
of the analysis is
leveraged through this platform.
So the data warehouse
is kind of a bigger
scale than the database.
It's really-- the
database, again,
is only storing that data
that we need to power
our specific application,
whereas the data warehouse
might, again, have the
current data, historical data.
It might have it in a structured
format, an unstructured format,
all these different things
that then can be put together
into a useful platform.
So that's the high-level
explanation or justification
for a data warehouse.
But nicely, it's not--
Redshift is specifically still
using a Postgres-compliant SQL
engine.
So things are going to look
very similar to PostgreSQL
if you're familiar
with that at all.
If not, we'll show you the
little bit you need for this.
I don't think
we'll even actually
have an explicit assignment to
set up a Redshift database just
because it's such a specific
use case that I don't think
it's worth our time to have
you guys do a designated
assignment on it, though I do
want you to be exposed to it.
Funny enough, Redshift was
actually the first AWS product
that I used of all
the AWS products.
So not EC2 instances, not
S3 instances, or S3 buckets.
The first one that
I explicitly used
was Redshift because
I was working
on an analytics workload.
I was working on a
very specific task
where we had a
massive amount of data
that was coming in every day.
On the order of hundreds
of gigabytes a day
of data that I was
working with, and I
needed to be able to perform
some sort of analysis on it.
So I guess to be more
specific on the problem,
this is back when I was
working for Carvana.
And we were trying to-- or
specifically, for my task,
the job I was working on, I
was trying to determine where
to list vehicles on a website,
or which specific car websites
where to list--
where should the
vehicles be listed.
So, for example, if you were
looking for a car today,
you might go to autotrader.com
or cars.com or CarGurus
or any number of car
websites that list used cars.
And at that time, at least--
this was 2014, 2015-ish,
somewhere around then--
[? no ?] car reps [? that ?] had
really heard of a national used
car retailer outside of CarMax.
And even CarMax still
only ever really sold cars
where they're
physically located.
We were saying that, well, we
can deliver cars nationally
so we should be able to
list our cars nationally.
They did not agree with
that mission at the time.
They do now and
it's all easy going.
I was actually still around
when those discussions
were happening.
But at that time,
initially, they
said, hey, Sharad, how do we
list these cars somewhere such
that we maximize their
probability of sale
and minimize the cost to list
them because some of them
wouldn't even let us list them
across multiple locations,
some would charge
us for every city
we physically
listed a vehicle in?
So even if I had a car that I
could sell in Dallas or Houston,
Texas, if I chose to list it
in Dallas and Houston, Texas,
they would charge me for
both of those listings.
So now I have this kind
of trade-off of, well,
what's the cost associated
with each of those,
and which one should it go into?
And so one component
of this was I
need to know what supply
looked like in the area.
And not just our available
supply because, remember,
our available supply is kind
of known and, to some extent,
constrained.
But I needed to know what the
rest of the market looked like.
And so one of the ways we
did this was, well, first
I had some crawlers that were
going out and collecting data
just from Craigslist
and listing sites.
But then we also
had another company
we worked with that had--
basically, their
whole business model
was they just scraped
individual dealership websites.
So they scraped the individual
dealership websites and then--
for example, "Larry H.
Miller, Volkswagen,"
or something like that.
They would grab
every car that they
had on their site every day.
And they would do this
across the whole country.
And every day,
they would give us
a dump of all vehicles
across the country.
And then I needed to go in
and say, OK, well, amongst all
those cars that
were listed today,
which ones were
listed yesterday,
listed the day before?
If the same vehicle is listed
multiple days in a row,
then I'm assuming
it hasn't sold.
If the same vehicle disappears,
then I'm assuming it has sold
or something has happened
that it's kind of transacted.
Could have been just
shipped off to a location.
It could have been
that all of a sudden
they determined it was a
lemon and they got rid of it.
But either way,
something happened.
So we have some assumptions
we have to make there,
but either way, we
have a ton of data
that's coming in constantly.
And I need to not only bring it
in and process it and structure
it because you can--
I'm sure all of you have been to
a dealership's website before.
They're not
necessarily the best.
They don't have the
most structured fields.
So a lot of that was
parsing that information.
And then from there, running it
through our statistical models
to then say which
location should it go to.
And again, this needs to happen
on at least a nightly basis,
potentially at a faster cadence.
And so that level of processing
is far and above of what--
or at least the time was
above what any other managed
service was able to do on
RDS, and so Redshift was kind
of the obvious solution for us.
And so because of that--
that is kind of my best use
case of why I, all of a sudden,
might want to step up to
something like Redshift.
Again, you can see here, it can
scale up to petabytes of data.
So where RDS, on the
order-- or was maxing out
at 64 terabytes of storage,
Redshift is petabytes.
So that's over a thousand
terabytes many times over.
There's really not-- you're not
going to hit the constraints.
You're usually going to run
out of data before you hit
the constraints on Redshift.
And they use a cluster-based
architecture for this.
So rather than just having--
spinning up a single
big RDS instance,
which is just a big
virtual machine that
houses all our data, they
say, instead, well, this
is kind of an inefficient way to
at least query this information,
as we might have the storage
located in one location
or in S3 or something like that.
But really, what I
want to do is when
I'm computing, I want to
have this data sitting
in a cluster of computers,
such that there's one node that
serves as the leader
node and their job
is to get the request
from the client.
That client might be the actual
user who's running a query.
It might be an application,
which is what ours was.
It was just an application
that said, give me this data
and process it.
And so they're going to
handle that communication,
the leader node is.
And again, [? the ?]
node is a computer,
right, so a virtual instance.
So the leader node
handles that communication
and then also plans
out the optimal way
to structure this query.
How should this query be
optimized and then executed?
And ideally, I should figure out
a way that-- or the leader node,
really, should figure out a
way, such that it can optimally
delegate this task
to many member nodes.
The more it can be
parallelized, the faster
this should be able to
run, because, the idea
is that most of the
things we're doing,
or at least a lot of
the things we could do,
can be parallelized.
And what I mean by
parallelize, if you're not
familiar with that concept,
is that in computing,
if I want to,
gosh, I don't know,
log into my bank, that has
to happen sequentially.
I have to go to the website.
I have to click
the login button.
I have to type in my
username and my password.
I have to click Submit.
Then there's likely going to be
a two-factor authentication that
sends a message to my phone.
I agree to it, and then
that sends that back
and it logs me in.
All of those steps have
to happen in order.
There's no way that I can do
each of those steps all at
once because they kind of
rely on the previous step
to be confirmed.
That is a serial process.
That is in order.
Nothing I can do about
that to speed it up,
outside of speed up
the individual steps.
A parallelizable
process, which is not
a word I want to
say 10 times fast,
parallelizable, a
parallelizable process
is something where
doing one thing
isn't dependent upon the
other thing happening.
Let's say that I have, I don't
know, a bunch of timesheets
that I have to approve.
I'm a massive corporation and
I have a bunch of time sheets
I have to approve.
The only thing
I'm looking for is
where there any
flags for managers
and/or did somebody go
over 40 hours a week.
And so the way I do this then is
rather than going from employee
one to employee two to
employee three, well,
I just calculate
all those at once.
I say-- for example,
I could have
one leader computer
that would say, OK, here
are all the 10 million
employees we have.
It's a massive company,
10 million employees.
I have 1,000 computers.
And so what I'll do is I'll
evenly split up each of those 10
million employees to
those 1,000 computers.
And maybe for whatever
reason, my software
can't handle doing more than
one timesheet at a time.
That's OK as long as I can
spread it across those 1,000
computers.
Then it'll go a thousand
times faster than
if I had to do this
all at once or I had
to do this all on one machine.
So that's this idea about
parallelizing a process.
And so Redshift is
specifically designed
to parallelize our queries,
our operations that we're
going to perform.
And the nice thing
is it integrates
a lot of standard
analytical calculations
that you might want to do
into its querying structure.
Meaning that it kind of limits
the amount of extra stuff
I have to do
outside of Redshift.
I can do a lot of stuff just
baked into Redshift right away.
Oops, I lost my screen here.
There we go.
So again, this is
kind of a visual image
of what Redshift
looks like or what it
looks like Redshift is doing.
So, again, client
application setup here,
that might be me sitting at
my computer, typing a query.
That might be some application
running in the cloud.
running on my computer.
It could be anything.
Then we're going to set up some
sort of database connection--
database connection, sorry,
to the machine itself.
And so ODBC stands for
Open Database Connectivity.
And JDBC is Java
Database Connectivity.
And that just is
the kind of language
that's used to communicate
between the application
and the software.
So you can set up an Open
Database Connection or a Java
Database Connection, depending
on what language you're using.
And that is how
you'll make requests
in the language of the data-- of
the data warehouse, the Redshift
instance.
And so, again, those
commands and those queries
are going to be sent
to the leader node.
And then the leader node
says, let me pass those out
to a bunch of
different compute nodes
that exist within my cluster.
Oops.
And so starting at the
leader node side of things,
this is kind of what it's doing.
So, again, like I
said, it's handling
all external and
internal communication.
Internal communication
being the communication
within the cluster.
External communication
being the communication
out to the client or the
tools that we're using.
It comes up with that query
execution plan whenever a query
is submitted to the cluster.
And then once it has
that plan figured out,
it delegates those
tasks, distributes them
amongst the compute nodes,
but also, importantly,
it also distributes
the slices of data.
So each of those compute nodes
will handle some number of--
some number of slices of data.
So this is just kind of an
extra step of parallelization.
So we can parallelize
across the compute nodes,
but also these compute nodes
themselves are computers.
They can also-- themselves, they
might have multiple processors,
multiple cores, so they
can probably also handle
multiple slices at once.
And so the idea is that we
parallelize across the nodes,
and within the nodes, we
parallelize across the slices.
And so the hope is that the
operations we're performing
can be completed on the
slices independently,
and then we just send back
the relevant information
to the leader node.
And so, like I said,
those compute nodes,
they handle the actual
execution of the queries,
though the plan is made
by the leader node.
And then they
execute the queries,
return those intermediate
results to the leader
node for aggregation.
And we have two different
types of compute nodes
we can choose from.
So we can choose from dense
storage and dense compute nodes.
And so dense storage
nodes are exactly
like they say-- they're
basically trying
to optimize storage for price.
So it's dense in
the terms of price.
A hard drive-- a hard
disk drive is much larger
than a solid state
drive, but it's
trying to create
the largest data
warehouse possible for
the lowest price possible.
So that's called the dense
storage compute node.
And the dense compute
ones sacrifice price
in the name of efficiency.
So if you know this is a really
high-performance workload,
you need to have
that high throughput,
you're going to have to
go with the dense compute.
That's going to give you
your fastest performance.
And then, like I said,
each compute node
is going to have multiple
slices with each slice utilizing
a portion of the node's
memory and disk space.
So it's almost partitioning
out itself and saying,
OK, well, I can handle--
I have enough memory to handle
a couple of different slices
of this size.
And I can operate on each
of those in parallel,
independent of each other.
And then the type
of node, obviously,
is going to determine
how many slices
and what size those slices
are per the compute node.
So the more you can have on
a-- or the larger the instance,
the more slices you can
have per compute node.
But this is kind of the
trade-off-- there actually
is kind of an
interesting optimization
problem within this,
of saying, well,
let's take the extreme example
of one really, really powerful
computer as our compute node.
And that one really,
really powerful computer
has a lot of ability to handle
a bunch of different slices.
So conceivably, we wouldn't
even need to pass it out
to a bunch of compute
nodes, but the idea
is that the effort to create
such a reliable and capable
system is much more expensive
than maybe me creating
a bunch of smaller instances,
a bunch of small compute nodes
that are very, very
cheap and I can almost
have them be redundant.
And to some extent, you will
have a level of redundancy,
such that I could send the same
slice of data to another machine
or to five different
machines and just say, "Well,
I hope you guys all come up with
the same result or you should
come up with the same result,"
and then I'll just verify that.
And that gives me,
actually, some really nice
statistical properties
to ensure that I
get the best result possible
or the most appropriate result
possible while also
minimizing the cost.
So that's one of the reasons
why this distributed computing
structure architecture is so
critical in analytics workloads.
And so, yeah, our
multiple compute nodes
now can execute that same query
code and portion of the data,
maximize parallel processing,
and minimize those costs,
and really compute time.
Another unique
component of Redshift
is that it utilizes
columnar-based data storage.
So most SQL databases
you're familiar with--
MySQL, Microsoft SQL Server--
all of those are
row-based storage systems,
whether you realized it or not.
Think about what they're
really trying to do.
They're trying to handle
transaction-level data
one row at a time, one
transaction at a time.
And that transaction
might be an actual sale.
It might be a user
hitting our website.
It could be any
number of things,
but it's at the row level.
And this is actually really,
really efficient for querying
for most standard queries
that you are probably
used to running.
That's the best way
to store that data.
It allows it to identify
primary keys and sort
and search very, very quickly.
And so that is one of the
reasons why they do leverage
that row-based storage.
But Redshift does
something a bit different.
It stores it in a columnar-based
fashion, which the idea here
is that the columns kind
of matter a little bit more
in the context of an analytics
workload because our columns
are our variables now.
They're the things
that can vary.
We're looking at this
as a big picture now.
We're not looking at an
individual transaction level.
And by storing in a
columnar-based fashion,
it will dramatically reduce the
input/output time on our disks
when we're running
any sort of query,
as well as the amount
of data we need to load
into memory to execute a query.
I don't need to know everything
to even-- for example,
if I wanted to
start sorting data,
I don't need to wait till I
have loaded in all the rows,
including all the values
for each of those rows.
I can just load in
one column at a time,
or I can just load in
the one column that
matters, sort that one, and
then map it back if necessary
to return other columns.
But the idea is
that I can just do
what I need because I might
just need to print out
a bunch of sorted
values, and therefore, I
don't need to return
every single row with all
the values in each row.
And so the
columnar-based fashion--
the columnar-based storage is
much more efficient for that.
If you're familiar with R, or
in Python, you might have seen--
I think we have used Pandas now.
I can't remember if we've
used Pandas explicitly or not,
or maybe even talked about
it, but Pandas is just
another columnar-based
storage system.
It's dataframes.
Those are-- better statement--
R and Pandas are
columnar-based storage systems,
so we have interacted
with them before,
whether we realize it or not.
And so we talked about
the last two points,
but again, when I'm thinking
about trying to average sales
price across millions
and millions of entries,
I don't really care to return
the user who bought the product.
But if I'm doing a query,
that to some extent kind of
has to happen.
I can't really ignore the fact
that that information exists.
And so I have to at
least load it up once
or I have to deal with a
little bit of I/O overhead just
to pull in the
actual sales price.
And then from there, I
can calculate the average.
So the idea is that I should
be able to just grab that
without having to worry about
those extra overheads for it.
So yeah, that's all I had
as far as differentiating.
Let me open up RDS now and run
through a quick, quick demo
of how we can start a cluster
and query some sample data.
So I'll pause and
come right back.
And I guess for now,
you can also launch AWS
and then we'll pull it up.
All right, so once
you've logged in--
and actually, I'd
recommend, for that matter,
probably, would use
your personal account.
We've been having
enough technical issues
with the university account
that I'd recommend using, again,
your personal account so that
we don't have any permissions
or connection issues.
It seems, really, it's the scale
at which we're doing things
since we have about 50 people
across both sections hitting
this and then people
creating multiple copies
and trying things out and
instance is not getting deleted.
So either way, we're ending
up running out of capacity
multiple times now,
which is kind of counter
to the whole mission of
cloud computing, which
is a different issue we'll
talk about in the future.
But for now, I think it'll save
us a little bit of headache
if you just run this on
your personal account.
Again, nothing we're
doing will cost.
And also, if you're
more comfortable with
or if you'd prefer not to
run anything regardless,
to save or avoid any
chance of anything
happening, then by
all means, we're
not going to do an
assignment on this.
But I do want you to see this
workload or this workflow,
better statement.
So either way, once you've
connected or logged in,
you can either click on
Redshift if you have it already
pulled up or as always,
just hit the Search button.
"Fast, Simple, Cost-Effective
Data Warehousing."
So I'll pull this up.
And now we need to
create a cluster.
So the easiest way to do it
is click Create a cluster.
And so in there, we need to
specify a unique identifier.
I believe this just needs to be
unique within our organization
or our account.
So if you're sharing--
again, if you're using
the university one,
it'll have to be
unique across there.
But I think if you're
on a personal account,
you can do anything that
you haven't used before.
So I'll just say
"redshift-cluster-sharad"
so I make sure that
if there's multiple,
I can easily find mine.
And then, obviously, we want
to run on the free trial
because there's no
reason to pay for it.
But once the free
trial ends, you'll
have to pay for
anything you use.
And be mindful, this can
be very, very expensive.
So here, you can see the
estimated on-demand compute
price.
And for that matter, here,
let me pull up the information
on the free trial.
I think it shows it
in here somewhere.
Let's see.
AWS Free Tier.
All right, so, yeah, as
part of the AWS Free Tier,
if your organization has never
created a Redshift cluster,
you're eligible for a two-month
free trial of our large node.
You get 750 hours
per month for free,
enough to continuously
run one DC2 with 160 gigs.
Once your two-month
free trial expires
or your usage exceeds
750 hours per month,
you can shut down your
cluster to avoid any charges
or keep it running at our
standard on-demand rate.
So again, I would recommend,
if you're running this,
run it on your personal
account with the free trial,
but don't keep it live
for any amount of time
because the prices
can run pretty fast.
So here, you can see that this
is on the free trial tier.
This is kind of
the smallest one.
It's one node, a
large node here.
We have two vCPUs.
The estimated on-demand
compute price is about $0.33
per node per hour.
And so that's what-- we're
using on-demand, obviously.
And then you're still
going to pay for the 160
gigabytes of storage.
So this is going to
be likely GP2 rates.
So GP2 pricing.
So what is that again?
Yeah, about $0.10 per
gigabyte per month.
So about 16 bucks per
gigabyte, or better statement,
about 16 bucks
per month for this
alone, for just
the storage alone.
And then $0.33
per node per hour.
So if you imagine if we're
running this for, let's see--
Let's, for example, say
that we have 10 nodes, which
is not unrealistic.
To have multiple nodes is
the whole point of this,
is to be able to scale this up.
But either way, if we had
multiple nodes, we had 10 nodes,
that means that's
$3.30 per hour.
If we ran this for
24 hours a day,
that's 80 bucks for the day.
And then across 30
days in the month,
that's 2,300 bucks a month.
So then there, again, showing
the best-case scenario here,
you're just running
the one node,
and you're still going to
have some pretty high costs.
But at this rate, you'd be
paying 2,300 bucks per month.
And if we divide
that by 10, that'll
give us the cost for
one node, so it's still
230 bucks per month
plus the 16 for storage.
So about 250 bucks to
run even the free tier
if you're not utilizing or if
you're outside of the free tier
range.
So keep that in mind.
Definitely, don't
keep this thing
live for any realistic
period of time
unless you're ready
to pay those costs.
But for now, this is fine.
It's just to show you.
So I'm going to start.
And actually, the nice thing is
it starts, by default, uploading
some sample data,
so we don't even
have to worry about how to push
or deploy this sample data.
So we'll just leverage
that as it is and then we
can look and see how we
can query it and whatnot.
And then also,
unsurprisingly, we
need to specify the username
and then a password for it.
So you can put-- just leave the
answer by default. It's fine.
And then I'll just
put a password.
There we go.
And then let's do
Create cluster.
And then we'll
wait a second here.
Why is-- I see.
Missing something.
Ah, my password
isn't complex enough.
Let's try this again.
There we go.
Now let's try it.
All righty, and we don't
need to save that password,
so let's do Never.
And so our Redshift cluster
is getting created now.
And so we're going to pause here
for now and then I'll come back
once we have--
once it's live.
All right, that took
about five or six minutes.
So once that's live
for you, though, then
you can go ahead and
click into the cluster.
And then under Query data,
you can click here and then
Query and query editor V2.
I haven't used V1, so
I'll have to figure out
what the difference is.
I'm sure there's just
some slight updates.
You also don't have
to use a query editor.
Kind of the same way that
we query from Python,
you could set up an
Open Database Connection
to query to your Redshift
cluster via any sort of Open
Database or Java Database
Connection-- connectivity.
So that's another way to
do it, but for now, I'm
just going to show quickly
that if we click on this,
it actually launches a nice
little query window for us.
And in here, it's just a nice
little interface where you
can explore example queries.
They have a bunch of queries
that you could share,
or we'll just do Create a query.
And so let's-- sorry,
where are we at here?
Oh, duh, I'm in a
query window already.
So, yeah, you should already
have the query window
up or at least one tab
up that you can query in.
And so I'm just going to
copy and paste a query,
an example query.
It's in the notes
as well, too, if you
want to use it from there.
I'm just going to copy
and paste this one.
It does a few things, not too,
too, complex, but selecting--
find total sales on a
given calendar date,
find top 10 buyers for a given--
actually, hold on
for one second.
I don't know if this is
where I can run them from.
Let's see here.
My queries.
I can't remember why we can't.
We need to save first.
Let's just save
this for a second.
The joys of working with a tool
as they change things on you.
Let me pause real quick and make
sure I tell you the right thing
so I don't waste too
much of your time.
I realized I just
hadn't clicked in here
and selected my
Redshift cluster.
So if you're in the same boat
like me and you can't read,
just click on this
little dropdown
in the Redshift cluster.
And actually, let's
just do one query first
so we can look at it a
little bit at a time.
So here we're just
selecting the sum
of some quantity sold,
where sales data ID
equals the date ID And so--
and calendar date
is set to this.
And I'm already
throwing errors in here.
Let me see.
Syntax error.
Pretty sure I just
copied this query here,
so let me just double-check,
make sure this is--
here we go.
Oh, and I guess you could have
dropped off the Explain graph,
but let's just do
limit 100 for now
so we just get the
first 100 results,
or I guess it's only going to
be one result because we're
doing the sum.
But let's do one
of the other ones
here where we might have
a little bit longer.
So here is find events.
So we're finding events
in the 99.9 percentile
in terms of all-time
gross sales.
So you can see we have a
nice subquery going on here,
just a good little
mess of a query.
We're doing some ordering.
So something that I would argue
would probably take a while.
We don't have a baseline
to compare it to right now,
but here, we'll just run it.
And we can see that,
in general, this
is actually a relatively
quick process to do.
They have a nice interface.
And so if you happen
to be in a situation
where you need to do
some advanced analytics
and you already have the
data or you have a way
to set up your Redshift
database or loading your data--
and we'll actually see
how to do that as well.
How to load in some data, too,
via S3 in the next lecture.
But then Redshift
is a great tool
to do some really quick
and fast and efficient
analytics at scale.
So we'll leave it at that.
Again, this is just
one of those ones
where I want you to see a tool.
And then the next lecture,
I'll show you again
how to pull in data
from an external source.
And then after
that, we'll be off
of database and
into some machine
learning and other
analytics-type workloads.
OK, thanks for watching.
Bye.
One final point before I go.
I forgot to show you that
we should delete this.
So you can close out of
your query editor here.
And then don't forget to
go to Actions and Delete.
And then you don't need to
create a final snapshot.
Type "delete" and then
hit Delete cluster.
So make sure you do that,
and then you're good to go.
OK, catch you later.
Bye.